it's great to be joined today by Lisa
Lacey who's a reporter for Adweek where
she covers technology and marketing we
are going to be talking today about
robots robotics human robot
relationships which will be will be a
thing at some point I mean maybe that's
a good place to start Lisa a lot of the
technology for sort of consumer robots
that could do a lot of day-to-day sort
of tasks chores activities the
technology is already out there why
haven't we seen more availability and
adoption of these consumer robots
I think price is probably the biggest
hurdle I mean you see a lot of these
robot startups geebo is one of them it
was very cute but it was like $900 and I
think $900 is a lot to ask for something
that essentially does the same things as
like an echo or a Google home even that
Sony came out with its robot dog not too
long ago and I forget exactly how much
money it was but it's thousands of
dollars so these these are still big
investments and I think that's why it's
delimited to early adopters can you talk
a little bit about the sort of
difference that exists between robotics
and artificial intelligence because I
think when you talk to a lot of people
about the future of robots interacting
with humans participating in humans day
to day lives there's sometimes some kind
of blurring about whether we're talking
about robots or AI or robots that learn
via AI we're really talking about two
separate things here though
yeah I mean it gets very complicated
very quickly I mean I think the simplest
definition is a robot is something that
can perform a task over and over again
whereas artificial intelligence is the
ability to exhibit human-like
intelligence and from there I mean the
lines blur and it gets very complicated
but that's sort of the simplest way to
put it in one article you wrote I read
that that there are a number of experts
who say that within 5 to 20 years humans
will be quote outsmarted by a I on the
other hand
chess is an area where robots or AI are
already
defeating humans jeopardy is another
area what is the difference between
these sort of narrow parameters where AI
can be better more intelligent although
maybe that's a cut not the right term to
use than humans versus what we're
talking about at some point in the
future well I mean you're right there's
no need to panic just yet I mean I think
there was a I think one of my favorites
was that thought that was fed a bunch of
names of paints and then asked to create
names for different colors of paint and
the names were often hilarious so I mean
it's it's sort of as it stands um you
know these artificial intelligence
things are very good at distinct tasks
and so they're not gonna take over the
world just yet but I mean I think one of
the things that I found in my reporting
is that you know we've never been at a
point in time where machines are smarter
than us and it's it's calming and that
was I think one of the most sort of
startling realizations for really though
the whole newsroom are the people that I
worked with on this story anyway because
I mean five to twenty years is not that
long and and we really don't know what's
gonna happen and so it sort of made me
question you know why are we doing this
if if we could solve a bunch of problems
that we haven't been able to solve on
our own but it could also sort of be the
end of humanity so it seems like a very
big gamble to me but I don't I don't
make those decisions well to be less
speculative I guess what's in
development now what's in development
now that that we know is sort of on the
the several year time horizon from some
of them maybe more well known tech
companies but also some of the ones that
are maybe less well known and specialize
in this area and what Amazon is
reportedly working on something I'm just
sort of take echo to the next level and
you may they're not commenting on that
but I don't think it's all that
surprising they've been
further and further into the home I
think I'm gonna get them mixed up but
there's a company thing called vector
and it has a robot called Anki a nki
that's kind of a cute little I don't
know machine guy and he's got eyes and
personality and stuff and they're really
focused on that emotional quotient in
addition to the the intelligence I mean
it's still you're looking at a very kind
of like echo like or Google home like
device that is gonna you know tell you
the weather and I think you can play
cards as well I don't think it can order
paper towels so again there's still
still a long way to go yeah what I mean
there's a huge psychological component
here when we talk about the sort of like
anthropomorphizing of these robots and
giving something like an AI a physical
presence that resembles what humans are
used to sort of interacting to in the
reporting and research you've done in
people you've talked to how much is that
being considered in the development work
that these companies are doing
I mean how human should they be or yeah
I think the answer is that if they'll be
very human I mean that sort of the the
initial question that I started with
when Alexa was laughing and sort of
creeping people out and I so I asked
that question you know how to mention
voice assistance being realized that
they're going to be very human and I
think in some of the research from
singularity net they talked about how
like in order to avoid killer robots
like they're working on on robots that
meditate and do good things and and
they're sort of hoping to counter I
think anything bad that comes from the
government or wherever else and a big
part of that is that they that they have
to have a human form in order to
interact with with people and it's it's
for us too it's it's it gives us sort of
a construct within to interact with them
I mean that's kind of why Alexa Google
assistant doesn't have a name but but
you know they have voices and they sort
of have personalities and it just sort
of to give us kind of a baseline to
interact with them and
they're as they take on bigger roles in
our lives they wouldn't be surprised at
all to see them also take on more sort
of human forms what's likely to be Oh to
sort of remain off-limits
for robots and AI if anything and I
guess that that could be for a couple
different reasons one would be that
there might be certain types of tasks
that robots and a I just can't do they
won't be able to do the other side would
be that as humans we might decide there
are certain tasks that we just don't
want to allow to be done by anybody
other than humans either or both reason
what are some of those tasks that you're
coming across well I think that was one
of the conclusions that I came to after
recording all of this is that as my my
friend Jason Snyder's that keep
technology officer at craft always says
that technology has surpassed our
morality in our legislation and that
eventually we're going to have to have
these conversations about what we want
robots to do what we don't want them to
do and kind of redefine some of what it
means to be human as well as our
expectations of privacy I mean these
these these things are collecting data
and you know they come from companies
that have their own sort of motivations
and goals having an Alexa or Google home
in your home is it's not just a handy
little thing to tell you what time it is
or what the weather is I mean they're
they're gathering data on you and
they're using that somehow so I think
just there has to be some kind of
conversation at some point about what
sort of limitations and and what role we
want them to play in our lives or or we
may end up getting kind of blindsided
yeah and I'm one of the other issues
that we've seen I mean just this week we
had extraordinarily uninformed elected
officials both Democrats and Republicans
asking very very strange questions to
Google CEO including for example asking
the CEO of Google to explain how their
competitor Apple's iPhone works so we
saw this with child porn legislation in
terms of what constitutes possessing it
on your computer and the law was very
far behind the sort of practical
realities we're already seeing it when
it comes to a lot of the tech regulation
are we not likely to get into this the
exact same problem but maybe even more
acutely when it comes to the regulation
of robotics and AI yeah for sure I mean
I think that's a very real possibility I
mean I feel like there's a lot of really
consumers are finally starting to
realize of how much data about
themselves is out there but whether that
ends up resulting in something like
regulations for Facebook Google etc I
don't know I've been really interested
in the decentralized web sort of the new
internet you ever watched HBO's Silicon
Valley that's sort of what they're
working on where the basic idea is you
you get rid of the middleman Facebook
Google Amazon whoever it is and just
it's it's very complicated but the
internet is made up of seven layers and
so if you're using Facebook Google
whatever you're you're on the top layer
the the a player with this decentralized
web your going further down and so I've
been curious whether and you're able to
since you don't need them you have to
sort of depend on each other that's why
they're called peer-to-peer networks for
fur storage and so I'm curious whether
ultimately consumers will revolt and say
that they don't like this and and go for
these peer-to-peer networks where they
can take more ownership of their data
but at the same time I was talking to
one of the sort of fathers of the
Internet who was telling me that uh that
he likened it to training to become a
Jedi like it's will require a much more
active role on behalf of users and and
people are generally pretty lazy so I
honestly don't know that's that's one of
the things that I'm really eager to see
in 2019 sort of how that plays out
the more that I read about this stuff
the more convinced I am that the
technology side of it is sort of just an
inevitability it's more of like a when
and in exactly what iteration then then
if sort of thing and the bigger
questions for me are what does this mean
about the role of humans in life right
and I'm curious whether you've talked to
some of the people that are working on
these technologies either on the
robotics or AI side about
once humans no longer are needed for all
of these different tasks what is it that
is going to fill the time on the planet
of what those people are doing like is
that something that they think about I
don't know I mean it's interesting that
you say that because I'm I'm feel like
I'm being a pompous jerk right now but I
am reading The Feminine Mystique
for the first time and sort of a similar
parallel in in there with sort of how
once once women housewives got vacuums
and washing machines and dishwashers
they they suddenly had all sorts of time
on their hands to sort of contemplate
what they were doing with their lives
which led to this sort of
dissatisfaction and and wondering what
was wrong with them and and and why they
weren't happy with what they had been
sort of told their whole lives they were
supposed to aspire to
so um I don't really I know I don't know
what it means I mean it's it's anybody's
guess I'm not sure we've figured out the
The Feminine Mystique part of it and
that's going on for quite a long time so
um so yeah I don't know what to say
about what we'll do when we have all
these robot but say it's safe to say the
people that are developing these
technologies they don't seem to be huge
on exploring that part at least not when
you're talking to them um you mean like
taking away jobs and things like that
just more generally I mean when you go
and you talk to someone who's working on
these projects either on the robotics or
AI side and you discuss what the
possible future uses are and how these
technologies will interact with humans
does it even come up does it even occur
to them to say yes and that will free up
humans to do I don't know
XYZ or that there's not really something
they talked about with you I am talked
to them about it's not to say that
they're not thinking about it I mean I I
feel like a big part of it is certainly
how to tap into these technologies to
you know make life better in the future
and
is sort of one of the hopes they think
that that these artificially intelligent
systems will be able to figure out
things that we haven't been able to
solve on our own um but again I'd said
what we'll see what happens I guess
right that's why this is sort of such a
huge huge gamble so I think one of the
things that I'm gonna look into some
point next year is it's sort of just
because we can build these things should
we yes that that's an important question
which increasingly people are emailing
me about we've been speaking with Lisa
Lacey reporter for Adweek where she
covers technology and marketing Lisa
thanks so much for talking to me today
thanks for having me